the year was 1991. it was a quiet night
in lethergy valley arizona the quietest
town in all of maricopa county seriously
despite the hardcore arizona dry heat
this is one of the most idyllic little
towns you could imagine everyone who
lived there knew each other by name and
regularly invited their neighbors to
wholesome neighborhood cookouts the
town's historic main street had an
old-fashioned ice cream parlor a
knitting supply store and even a
build-a-bear workshop and of course a
few local car dealerships and auto body
shops lethargy valley really is just the
sweetest calmest place you could
possibly imagine and tonight my friends
it's going to rock while the citizens of
lethargy valley went about their evening
duties something hardcore was heading
their way rumbling across the scorching
arizona deserts burning fuel and
belching smog the hottest hot rods this
side of the sun we'll so fly they're
ready to take off with riders so badass
their own reflections are scared of them
that's right these are the high octane
full throttle adventures of the
exploding zombie gear heads and they're
about to give this sleepy arizona town a
four loko enema the sun was sitting on
lethargy valley when the lights of
distant fire cut through the night
citizens and shopkeepers enjoying an
evening summer breeze halted in town as
the redness in the east got closer and
brighter they could feel the rumble of
torqued up subwoofers rattling the
ground the roar of the engines felt more
fitting on 747s than road legal cars and
when the distance was close enough that
they could taste the vapors of burning
gasoline in the air they could finally
hear the laughter 2. meet scp-3885-01
also known as the exploding zombie gear
heads probably the most medal of all
anomalies on the scp foundation catalog
but let's talk about them before these
gas chugging dust devils were just
another number in the man's filing
cabinet because these bad boys don't
care about filing they only care about
defiling they rolled into lethargy
valley like a pack of easy riding
coyotes on gearhead steroids their skin
is green from rot and covered in cuts
lesions and gnarly burn scars some have
their heads completely cracked open
exposing what little brains they have
underneath others have fully opened rib
cages and disemboweled bellies but they
don't care these ain't your grandpa's
zombies forget the walking dead these
dudes are the riding dead romero meets
ratfink after 10 lines of colombian bam
bam and a gallon of monster energy drink
decked out in a patchwork of motorhead
style leather and stolen clothes and you
best believe these fun dead freakazoids
are here to party hardy paulie poundtown
rounded the corner of main street first
on his ride the murderlizer in past life
had been a coffin but now with the aid
of two monster truck wheels on the back
and a pair of circular saw blades on the
front it was a vehicle ready to tear up
the streets
literally paulie drove down the road at
a breakneck pace leaving a trail of
sparks and black smog behind him he was
screaming something about being king of
the world when the vehicle exploded
underneath him the force of the boom
flung paulie down the length of the
street he hit the window of a local
barber shop and shattered through like a
fleshy missile for a moment he lay on
the tiles a leather pincushion of broken
glass and wooden shrapnel from the
recently detonated mertilizer but at no
moment in this whole insane ordeal did
polly stop laughing he got up noticed
his neck was twisted backward at an odd
angle we told you it was a breakneck
pace but paulie just grabbed that sucker
and crunched it back into place it'd
take a little more than a totaled spine
to stop paulie poundtown after all the
night's fun was only just starting more
tricked out zombie roadsters were
pouring into the town from every angle
hopped up on a combination of tequila
lighter fluid and some stuff we can't
even mention if we want to keep
monetization on this video steely dan
was roaring into the build-a-bear
workshop on a modified toilet with all
crushing caterpillar tracks once he
busted through the facade he dismounted
his porcelain throne and began
incinerating walls of teddy bears with a
custom flamethrower powered by a tube
going into his stomach cavity once he
was done burning 90 of the bears in the
store he used the remaining unsullied
parts to make a grungy looking bear in
his own likeness he strapped it to the
front of his terrifying mobile toilet
and then burnt that too
just for the fun of it bareback boris
was making a bee line for the ice cream
parlor riding what would look like a
bowl to the untrained eye it was
actually a taxidermied bowl gutted and
fitted with a nightmarish configuration
of motorcycle parts that would function
better together as a method of execution
than a workable vehicle but that's just
how the exploding zombie gear heads like
it boris pulled the handbrake which was
made out of some old bones he dug up
once and ground the bowl cycle to a
screeching halt in front of the parlor
he climbed off and kicked in the door
before running in to cause some chaos
boris the animal that he was grabbed
handfuls of gelato and shoved them into
his mouth before turning and spitting
them at the wall he pulled out a bottle
of 90 vodka and took a long swig before
taking a quartz summons out of his
jacket and shoving it into the bottle he
lit the top of the litigious fuse with
his lighter which was shaped like a
knife and made a molotov cocktail
moments later the whole store was in
flames borah stepped out of the burning
ice cream parlor on fire but utterly
unfazed he pulled out no less than four
cigars and lit them on his own burning
skin before smoking each one in a single
pole if his lungs didn't already look
like blackened lumps of decaying coal
they would have been screaming at him
but right now the only person screaming
was gene simmons of the band kiss as
some of boris's fellow writers rampage
through the streets past him unholy
blaring from their radios at ear
exploding volumes the exploding zombie
gear heads didn't throw out of town
ragers like this often but when they did
they always tried to make it one for the
history books and before you start
worrying about the safety of the
citizens of lethargy valley arizona you
should know that the zombie gear heads
never hurt anybody well never hurt
anybody on purpose that is if a piece of
stray shrapnel from an exploding camaro
reshaped with scrap metal to look like a
giant fist spraying fire from its
knuckles happens to take out somebody's
eye well that can't really be seen as
anybody's fault can it especially when
you don't have eyes anymore the closest
thing to the brains of this operation
which for these guys really isn't saying
much was a free-thinking free-spirited
free liquored individual known as joey
nuts the whole gang had probably about
40 brain cells between them but at least
five of those cells belonged to joey
while many of his rotting buddies were
goofing off and causing mayhem across
town joey was already acting on the real
reason everybody was here getting new
parts for their sick is all hell car
mods sure as mechanics they couldn't
produce actually workable vehicles worth
a damn but at the end of the day isn't a
vehicle looking awesome much more
important than boring old functionality
if you think otherwise you're probably
just a square but we digress back to
joey
nuts joey and a crew of his boys
including dirty mike scuzzy steve and
generally unclean gary rolled up to one
of the local auto body shops and bashed
the door down with their vehicle which
by the way was a modified suv modified
with bulldozer parts and a makeshift
cannon it was a powerful if structurally
unsound motorized siege weapon joey and
the boys jumped off the vehicle and
stormed into the building wielding pipe
wrenches with nails and fishing hooks
welded onto them a confused mechanic was
quaking in his boots as the gaggle of
zombie gear heads approached him joey
stood at the front swinging his pipe
wrench around with menacing randomness
he was chewing 12 toothpicks making him
look extra tough the mechanic with a
quiet trembling voice told joey and the
boys that they needed to leave they
weren't supposed to be back here they
needed to leave and come back during
opening hours it was the most polite
telling off he could possibly muster the
exploding zombie gear heads just laughed
once they were done cackling joey lifted
up his pipe wrench and pointed it at the
terrified mechanic's face joey cleared
his tobacco and gasoline burnt throat
and said listen you stupid grease monkey
i'm only gonna say this once so open
your ear holes real wide and listen up k
you're gonna pack up your crap and leave
so me and my boys can loot this place to
our hearts content and beef up our sick
ass rides and if you don't leave
you're gonna be holding this here pipe
wrench for me in your prison pocket you
get me the mechanic definitely got him
he didn't waste a moment in hightailing
it out of the store while joey and the
boys pulled a classic smash and grab on
his wares they stole everything from
whole cars to wrenches and lug nuts
across town the exploding zombie gear
heads were doing the exact same thing
stealing or stripping every vehicle in
sight and cannibalizing the parts for
their own righteous whips town by town
vehicle by vehicle explosion by
explosion they'd one day figure this
whole mechanic deal out with the knights
revelry finally concluded it was time to
return home and get to work on the next
set of rides this legion of awesome
unkillable morons piled back into their
stylish death traps and rode off into
the misty dawn leaving hundreds of
thousands of dollars in property damage
behind them but not a single death as
hyper destructive anomalies go they're
honestly pretty benevolent or at least
too self-centered to be truly malevolent
they tore up the desert on their way
back to the real scp-3885
vulture gulch the home of the exploding
zombie gear heads it's a desert shanty
town that's officially been abandoned
since july 9 1973 due to high volumes of
dangerous radeon gas being emitted from
the uranium deposits in a nearby mine
but these intense joy-riding mutants
hardly mind a little bit of radiation in
their sweet pad be it ever so
radioactive there's no place like home
right some of the vehicles even exploded
on the way back to the place but the
boys didn't mind the flaming explosion
survivors just crawled out of the fire
and hopped onto the rides of their
closest buddies all in all everyone in
attendance had a damn good time that
night they'd spend the rest of the early
morning setting rocks on fire for fun
and chewing on ignited fireworks that's
the kind of brain trust we're dealing
with here when the foundation eventually
contained them in vulture gulch the
gearheads didn't even put up a fuss as
long as the foundation kept supplying
them with three decommissioned vehicles
every month it's a pretty sweet deal a
crazed car lover's paradise where as
long as you keep it within the walls
anything goes baby but there is one
strange little detail a question that
remains unanswered drones sent in by the
foundation to spy on the residents of
vulture gulch have picked up one strange
recurring theme in their chatter
mentions of an individual known only as
the boss paying them a visit and we can
only assume they don't mean bruce
springsteen the only clues we have are
that the gearheads believe this boss
created them and put them here on this
earth to be totally rad the other clue
is a seemingly pervasive belief that
someday soon the boss will return who do
you think the boss of the exploding
zombie gear heads truly is let us know
down in the comments now go check out
top 15 most dangerous scp monsters in
containment an evil monster created by
the scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing men for more of
the biggest bad boys in foundation
history